this is the difference between Bitcoin
and a central bank digital currency
Bitcoin is completely decentralized
there's no one founder or a CEO which
can program the money with the Central
Bank digital currency it's basically a
digital version of what we have now
there's nothing different to it it's
going to be entirely centralized in the
control of the government and the
central bank so if for whatever reason
you hold the incorrect opinion they can
just program the money and use it
against you so if you like the wrong
thing on social media the Central Bank
digital currency will no longer work
with Bitcoin nobody can touch it it's
entirely in your possession you'll have
a non-custodial wallet and that is where
you'll hold your Bitcoin and nobody has
access to that